hasta el momento la conocíamos como
variante andina
ahora la ms la ha denominado como el
lanza no sólo es un cambio de nombre
lanza pasa ahora a considerarse como
variante de interés una denominación
bajo la que se encuentra en otras seis
variantes en todo el mundo primera y más
leve de las tres clases de variantes que
clasifica la o ms seguida de las
variantes preocupantes en última
instancia a la denominación alta
consecuencia que por el momento no
cuenta con ninguna variante registrada
landa no es una variante nueva fue
detectada por primera vez en perú en
agosto de 2020 pero tras un largo
monitoreo la o ms señala su mayor
capacidad de transmisión comunitaria el
organismo estudia si lambda podría tener
mutaciones que la hacen más contagiosa y
resistente a los anticuerpos el campo de
acción de esta variante es
principalmente américa latina' en perú
la variante supone ya el 81 por ciento
de los casos monitoreados desde abril en
chile representa asimismo el 32 por
ciento de los casos reportados en los
últimos 60 días similar a la incidencia
de la variante brasileña en este país
argentina por su parte informó de una
incidencia del 37 por ciento entre el 2
de abril y el 19 de mayo ahora la oms se
deberá estudiar si lanza podría dar el
paso a variante de preocupación